Now, how do we get out and how do we attack? Taniguchi, we'll
make a decision here. [Applause] [Music] It's not a goal, but our lack of decisiveness is exposed here.
[Music] That's quite a
suffocating battle. It's
getting frustrating, isn't it?
Such a passive attack.  On the other hand, I
can't get any points against Mr. Yanagi, right?
Mental weakness is fatal.
Well, Mr. Yanagi seems to be slow at things like this too. I see. You're the
same type as my husband, no, no, I'm
the type who understands things pretty well, right?
But that's about it.  If you're slow, there's a chance that you'll go the wrong way.This
attraction is dark and a
bit
scary, so it's pretty
exciting.Well, Mr. Taniguchi, I'm quite nervous, so
could you please hold on to me until it's over?  It has
been decided